have any of you ever looked at an ex's
Instagram or Facebook to see how they're
doing after a breakup yeah all the time
has anyone ever done that anyone
two two okay so the majority oh two what
do you what do you I shouldn't put my
hands up ready because nobody open up on
Facebook
you're half raising drinks I don't know
if I should say too much
um yeah I haven't do you guys get mad if
the girl you feel like is prettier than
you or better looking not just happy
you're you're happy for that yeah
it depends on how soon after yeah break
up yeah so how how soon would would piss
you off versus how soon would make you
happy for them
after she's moved on yeah
[Laughter]
one better looking than me
does it depend on the X too like how
much you liked the X whether you're
happy for them or mad no no just happy
to move on so I I kind of look at life
as lessons so for me not to be with
someone I mean it's taken me a while to
get here to be fair but it's my stance
now it wasn't previously possibly maybe
before but
I think everyone
there's a reason behind everything and a
why and I think
if we're not meant to be together then
we're not meant to be together
be happy
good luck to the next person
I mean that's just kind of mad I mean I
don't wish you the best
it's taking me a long while to get here
but yeah I just think yeah completely
understand that as well I think if it's
a bad breakup you think you've seen with
somebody else you think yeah she's I'm
glad she's got you I ain't got you
I was going to say this is a problem
it works both ways but then if it was a
good breakup you know you just split you
just speak to yourself
because she ain't gonna be as good as me
but well done
because we're in the [__]
you're not going to say you're going to
be happy for someone who's proud of them
come on but it's a bad breakup better
than a good one
I don't know is it bad what do you mean
it's about like if I if I know was to
break up with someone there's either two
ways I can break up one we have like the
most craziest fight and I say [__] you
and I leave or it could be right we're
gonna sit down and talk we're gonna
figure this out why it didn't work out
by the end of the day I just don't want
to be with you and it's both on both
parties it's the same what's going to
help me like in which circumstance am I
going to be like yeah you know what if
you moved on to another girl I'll be
like yeah good for you do you get it
because either way if if we end up in a
fight and you left I'll be like good for
you so which would you prefer the bad
breakup or the
amicable okay sit down and talk like I
that's what I'd prefer anyways well
sometimes if it's a bad breakup it's
just like it makes you get over it
faster you think so that's why I'd
prefer the bad ones because it's just
like done and out of the way I mean it's
like you don't because you don't want to
deal with the drama of it but at the
same time then you're just over it
you've got things to say I don't think
that was a bad breakup what Intel is a
bad breakup it sounds all crazy can I
hear what everybody's what's your worst
breakup ever been like
um because it sounds like you said
they're doing something crazy
after I ended it he broke into my flat
and hid in my wardrobe oh my god wow
okay okay
she spoke oh [__] you're looking over
there
so okay
who broke up with who I so it was quite
bad I ended it with him but he had
nowhere to go and I said oh I will
support you you live ticket was he a bum
was he living with you yeah I was paying
the rent okay okay
um
was it was he hot
how tall was he damn it should have been
too long just you don't say that to her
you say was he good in bed
I was better in bed no wonder he broke
in
okay okay so you break up with him then
what happens
um so I supported him
through the breakup obviously so we
could get his own place because I knew
if I kicked him out he turned back up on
my doorstep
don't want that so he moved out
everything was fine I was even praying
to God let please just let this go
nicely
he left
about two a month later I'm hearing my
name outside my house I'm thinking
what the hell calling my family
everyone's saying are you sure you're
not having a mental breakdown
they actually believed I was losing my
my mind
um and then on my birthday which was
like a month after that
it broke into my house he was hiding in
my wardrobe and um
yeah it just went like he didn't come
out but I could smell him in my house
how long was he there before I don't
know no seriously because he was outside
and I ran up the night I took my heels
off and run up four flights of stairs
and then I've gone in shut the door
behind me and everyone's trying to get
in and I was just like when I find you
it's over
um I could just smell him on my flat and
I couldn't find him and then I left and
he broke out afterwards
I've heard of a woman that's breaking
into a man's house I've heard of a woman
breaking into a man's but it's the first
time I've heard of a man breaking Auntie
what are you doing if someone stands at
your house like that and comes inside
him now you're inside your mind
That's the Law That's the Law isn't it
my property your inside I never invited
you you know I'm I'm not leaving you
have to get past me
are we fighting them
I'm not fat and I'm defending myself
because I'm at the door there's a
difference okay legally that's what I
mean I know what I'm saying I know what
I'm saying
what else who else anyone yeah crazy
wake up worst breakup is it worse
breakup or is it worth the person if the
person is bad yeah the worst breakup I
wanna hear yeah
I want to hear that I say oh they're
nice breakups if they ever nice breakups
has anyone had a nice breakup I've had a
nice breakup have you yeah most of them
have been nice yes there is there is
nice breakup guys
what happened
uh do I really want to go into that
um I'll just move over it did you do it
yeah so
way back in my past I'm not gonna go to
my recent way back in my past
um I had someone that was a bit
obsessive actually
he left he finished the relationship and
then
he thought he could go away for the
weekend mess around a bit and come back
and I'd had enough and I said No and
then
um
he was Finding Me In This streets on his
hands and knees crying begging you know
yeah it's a bit messy
and he would try and break in but he
didn't ever succeed he was trying to
break it yeah he put a ladder up to the
window and also there was a lot there
was a lot
yeah he didn't he didn't get in but it
was very weird yeah
[Laughter]
so he put a ladder onto your door and
tried to or um to the second yeah and
then tried to get
it to get in yeah did you call the cops
did I call her do you know it was a long
time no I don't think I did I think I
just
got out of the way of the way he
couldn't get in so what was he gonna do
it's just stupid it was just such a
stupid thing to do okay you go off a
ladder go back down again see ya yeah so
all right have fun wow that's I can't
believe there's two people in here yeah
he didn't succeed though and he didn't
hide in a wardrobe
I mean he did do some weird things over
the year but I'm not gonna go into stuff
is dating a younger more attractive man
than your ex considered a win why or why
not
doesn't it depend on how he treats you
and what person he is
um how he carries himself whether he's
holding doors open for you whoever all
those nice things that you like from a
man to be treated like
a woman
um is he doing those things does age
really matter
can I just say if I was to date a
younger guy then I am like was dating or
I'm dating whatever the situation may be
I'd probably catch a case
it's crazy
I've got a bit of
leaving leeway I'll put some leeway the
questions based on the um Tom Brady so
okay she was dating a 24 year old is she
she's 40 something I mean I don't know
if I'd want to date a man that's that
much younger because it takes a man
takes men a while they have to get some
things out of their system before they
settle down and
yeah they mature a lot slower I don't
know if I'd want to do that a little bit
and you've got to look it is are you
actually looking to have a are you
footage younger person you're actually
looking to have a relationship I don't I
don't date without having a relationship
I don't get involved with anyone unless
I see a relationship potential I don't
do that sorry one thing that I would
point out is women typically don't want
younger men and attractivists and what
secondary
um I think for men
if they had a you know a younger more
attractive
um new person than their ex then it
would be a win for them because that is
kind of their dating metric that's what
they look for whereas with women I would
typically look for someone that's older
like my partner's a little older than me
um
and attraction you know a lot of times
women can replace that with for example
you know status or money whereas with
men if you're not attractive they won't
even give you the time of the day so it
is the question was kind of asked in
Reverse it wouldn't be you know a win
for women but definitely for men I think
I think that it'd be a win for women if
the younger person as a younger person
if the younger person was a
more mature
because sometimes you get a younger man
he's more mature than the older man
you've left is it rare it's rare though
isn't it
am I ever seen
yeah but it's the man rare I know you're
a rarity but no sometimes no there's a
lot of good young men out there no but
then if you're actively going out
seeking a younger guy saying oh yeah
this is going to make my husband thought
[__] like I'm gonna go with that he's
gonna be like oh he's probably more
sexually active probably more good
looking probably has better things
coming for him I think that's kind of
that's kind of like he tapped like high
key in fact like if you're thinking
about getting with someone to degrade
someone that you've been with before it
kind of just shows your character and I
don't think that's how we should be
approaching it especially right now and
as women I don't think that's how we
should approach it before we get there
with our stuff we don't want to so I
agree I think that's good I agree for
the different reason that's slag
Behavior
don't forget that if it's if it's like a
40 year old woman and a 25 year old man
what could what future could there be no
matter how nice of a young man he is
she'll get good sex for about 10 years
before he leaves her
but no I mean okay
so would you say that's a win then for
her oh it's a win for her
good honor that's nice
I'm gonna talk about equality in it and
that the younger man oh good on him he's
out there of an older woman has got a
bit of dush why not
I think some men like older women
and I don't know whether it's mummy
issues but I feel like they like to be
mothered and I think older women
tend to wrap them up and look after them
yeah I just think that older woman knows
how to look after a man rather than the
young people nowadays so what you might
see is Mother it might be just a
traditional woman looking after a man
and that's what it is because if you get
an older woman there and she decides to
go and give a man dinner on a go and
cook dinner and put it on the tree you'd
be like
see what I mean and you might think oh
she's my real name but that's what women
do well and younger guys like the guys
that I know that will go for older women
is typically because they want casual
sex and they just think it's easier to
get it from them yeah that's what I said
good sex or ten years
[Laughter]
and if it lasts longer that's a bonus
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible